okay we're
live should be at
least let me make sure everything's
working it looks
good it's been a
while let's
see chat's not working hold
on continue with Google
that's
annoying let me get the chat window
back ah hey pram how's it
going let me fix the chat when actually
I can see it on the stream now so this
is fine there's going to be a little bit
more of a delay though if I don't have a
separate
window
perfect so I'll talk about everything
that happened at nurs in a bit once the
stream warms up
um because I've been gone a while and
I'm probably still going to be out for a
few more days over the holidays is the
audio and everything good I messed with
the setup a little bit
on couple terminals
and I'll move this
browser hi are you going to be on Twitch
and YouTube as well I should already be
live there uh if I not let me know am I
like peeking out on the
microphone hold on I I think I need to
add a compressor to this yeah cuz I
moved the mic hold
on test
okay well let me know if the default
compressor is uh is any
good but yeah I should be live right now
on X uh YouTube and twitch mic sounds
good okay perfect I moved it I finally
got a cable for it so I have it's
actually in the shot right now so let's
fix
that yeah and I've got to like do
something with this camera cuz I'm kind
of stuck in this little box here I
should have gotten a wider green screen
but
whatever we'll uh we'll upgrade this set
up since I'm going to be back streaming
a lot now really mostly starting in the
new year um or at least after Christmas
but apparently I broke a whole bunch of
stuff with the release and I also have a
ton of new people on the Discord that
have made new environments for puffer Li
so that's pretty cool uh I'm going the
goal for today is just going to be to
fix anything that's Jank with the
release and start onboarding some people
uh I'll talk a little bit about what I
did at nurs and some cool new stuff that
we've got planned for
puffer um but yeah it's going to be very
very exciting at Le starting in uh
starting in the new year if not before
so first of
all I don't think I changed anything
while I was away at nurs nurs was really
busy I was hoping I was going to be able
to fix some stuff remote yeah but I
didn't that's fine
now people were telling me like the
container doesn't work or something
which that would be very
weird uh believable though
blastar the background noise is not
coming through on the mic now
right hope
not okay there's a whole bunch of stuff
to catch up on here um I think that the
initial thing I was told is that I just
had to pointed to the wrong container
and that there were a few issues with
setup
tools go to the docks here
okay so apparently I just messed up the
docker file which is kind of
weird cuz if people are getting the
instructions off the
website I am on 2 did I remember to
update the doer 22 though I might have
not updated the default Branch that's
like a common screw up of mine
tank ah I am
dumb
so yeah that that was just really stupid
uh
Branch I should have a two
Branch oh I never pushed
it well that will do
it oh my God I don't know how I messed
that up
there's always something just stupid
that you forget you know and it's this
is the thing that sucks about having to
go straight from a release to a
conference is like this only takes me a
few minutes to figure out what I've done
but that's like when I'm fresh and
rested and not thinking about a million
conference things like I could very
easily like be spinning my wheels not
knowing why stuff doesn't work like
trying to do stuff on my old laptop for
mode
like um to be fair I could have probably
fixed this like earlier on Monday or
something I didn't know it was going to
be this dumb I thought it was going to
be something
harder uh this all looks fine Yep this
is what I
expected talk depths
tank apparently I didn't do the I don't
have my credentials C
find that one
line I always have to stack Overflow
this I should just remember this I
always use this
thing and let me go get myself a new
token not on the uh stream window
obviously and then the actual the puffer
tank thing will work so technically the
puffer tank container was uploaded uh
you just had to point to it manually but
I forgot to upload the Bas Docker file
so I had the image but not the container
my bad I will fix that up right
now it's really awesome just to see the
amount of stuff that people are doing
though in the uh the rep oh by the way
1.4 uh oh yeah for folks watching if you
haven't started the repository please go
ahead and start the repository um you
know it makes me very sad that we were
kind of like the fastest growing RL
project of the year year and then
somebody comes in and lies about their
performance numbers by a factor of like
at least 10 and then this happens
so give me a star for Christmas please
helps us a
lot let me get out let me get the
key I'll tell you what you start the
repository and I'll get you a working
container right
now I really don't know how I messed
that
up I just like straight up forgot to
commit just straight up forgot to commit
actually do I have one of these already
I might actually have a CH already
token so we'll fix this and then I think
that there might be something with setup
tools with the packaging uh but the
thing is when I fix that everything will
just work
it's very funny though like as soon as I
go people start like as soon as I'm out
for a few days people start submitting
like crazy
things um so like I think people thought
that like I had to rename every
single uh people thought that like I had
to rename every single function or
something like literally thought that I
had to rename every single function in
all the new environments so that the
names wouldn't conflict or something I
don't know where this came up with so
like yeah that's I'm not going to mess
up that badly
guys if anything like I'm not going to
submit code that's fundamentally broken
at the most I'll have like forgotten to
check in a specific like file or
something or I'll have like added a bad
build system
work
boom now we go make this the default
rench and we will be
good and I will test it as well before I
go tweet it
now I think we'll do um a clean build of
this or a clean version of
this just to make sure that you guys
actually have everything really easy out
of the
box uh we're going to name
this puffer
found oh well that's because I'm in the
container
deal just going to install Vim on this
because no we'll just go do
had ah okay already
exists you know I can just stop the
previous container that's that's going
to be easier
so we'll make sure that this
works maybe I'll tell some ner stories
we'll say maybe I'll get some people on
boarded there's still a few lingering
things that I've got to deal with so
I'll have to get up for like 10 minutes
in a bit but
okay so puffer
lib Ranch
latest okay so the container has the
right version on
it um
native works perfectly okay so I'm not
an idiot I just had the wrong people
were just using the wrong
container um because well my fault
so you can see here this is over a
million steps per second
training I don't know if this GPU
utilization is Right technically we
could get this double speed if it
is um but
yeah that was mug V1 glad to see you
back back thanks this is not mug V10
this is um this is just
tea I um I got sick after NS and just it
asked through it I've gotten fat anyways
I'm going to do a quick just like a
quick one we cut cut a couple pounds of
fat um it's pretty damn easy for me to
maintain like a th000 calorie deficit so
cut a couple pounds of fat I'm down to
like 185 186 lb now and then next
training block we're going to see I'll
put some weight back
on duh it's not necessarily duh with the
amount that I train is the
thing obviously I've been out this week
sick and then from Nerfs and stuff but
normally I'm doing between two and three
hours of exercise a day um including you
know a decent run and uh some heavy
weights oh Del was for the tea I don't
know I don't know what angle you can see
can you I guess if I do this
but the same mug I
use I do highly recommend the um the mug
though it's a great way to get a ton of
protein uh it's specifically for people
who need who like train a lot need to
get in calories and do not have the
appetite um that's basically me but
there are some people that fit that
category mostly skinny
nervs okay
so we can uh should we just stop this
now
yeah there's probably some other stuff
in that
container actually I want to work in the
clean
one yeah let's work in the clean one for
a
bit all right so what other stuff did
people say was
broken I guess if people on stream don't
have specific stuff I'll just start
scrolling through here and
um I don't know I'll tell the Nerf stuff
when more people are around so I don't
have to repeat a bunch of things but
there there are some cool stuff that
happened with
Nerfs I have some fun
stories oh my gosh look how many
messages I missed it's great that it's
that
active guys this is
12:15 okay what date did I leave cuz I
got to just go through all the damn
messages
now so I left
on I don't think I have to I don't think
it heated up
until okay so I left on like the
[Music]
10th okay uh we'll see how many new
environments there are and if if people
are interested in contributing or doing
stuff here you just feel free ask a ask
away mostly why I do the streams to help
people get into this
stuff almost to the top of course I got
to do General as well 11 one more
okay you know what I'll actually try to
get my end working with puffer lib while
you're live
awesome yeah that's the uh that is the
goal
here I'm probably going to do two
streams today what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do this morning block of
stream and then I'm going to go get
brunch and then I'm going to come back
and do
an afternoon stream and that's probably
going to be my schedule for a lot of